foreign  [Music]  what's wrong Ryan do you have any idea  what it's like to be in a Will Ferrell  Christmas movie that's not helpful yes I  was there when we shot it I don't think  they're expecting elf yes they are  instead they're they're getting a  musical from two guys with questionable  pitch hey hey hey  sorry  it's okay this is easy some simple  disclaimers hey everyone spirited is not  elf it's not Deadpool either it is a  musical it is funny anything else it's  on Apple TV plus where the hell is that  [Music]  thank you  will and I are so excited for you to see  our movie musical spirited now we want  to dispel the rumors that we didn't do  all the singing ourselves this is 100  pure Ryan and will here  hold on a second  sorry Ryan it's been a long time since  I've done this  I thought you sounded great Ryan thank  you will  nailed it  [Music]